mais vous allez la faire vous
l'attestation comme quoi vous êtes
d'accord pour passer à la télé pour la
caméra cachée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
il faut pas alors
tu sais pas où tu es là j'ai payé en
plus
j'ai payé au mec du camping
il m'a dit le emplacement numéro 8
heures à la montée déjà
dormir encore une heure ou deux on vous
a dit quoi on nous a dit que maintenant
vous sortez de là
moi je veux pas de gens qui viennent
jouer à côté de ma tante
maintenant jusqu'à présent on parle très
gentiment on peut parler autrement si
vous voulez
autrement comment ça
priez pas j'ai mal au crâne
c'était sympa mais oui
[Rires]
j'arrive pas à dormir
non non non non
c'est parce que j'ai des copains c'est
mon bizutage
j'ai les clés dans la poche
dans ma poche
c'est quoi ça c'est des menottes là dans
ma poche là là ici j'arrive pas à
attraper
donc
c'est pour te rendre service
s'il te plaît
[Musique]
sinon j'ai la clé dans la poche attendez
parce que là ça va pas le faire
je suis désolé je suis parti trop vite
c'est des conneries oh non pas mon
blouson
alors regarde
[Musique]
c'est super
regardez moi je
non non mais c'est moi qui est intéressé
je vais en faire une comme ça c'est
rigolo
on met des petites légendes maintenant
ici on est mieux qu'au bureau
[Musique]
enlever votre main parce que je vois
plus vos seins maintenant
un peu un peu chaud quoi prenez une
pause plus [__] encore voilà
bon maintenant badigeonnez-vous de
chocolat
merci tu connais au magasin
[Musique]
regarde ce que tu as fait
tu as pas compris ou quoi là ça va pas
passer
c'est interdit les portables sur la
plage et oui sur la place
parce que ça fait chier tout le monde
le récupérer au commissariat
[Musique]
pour récupérer ou pas
voilà d'accord
[Musique]
voilà comme ça on l'entend plus
je vais le téléphoner à la télé parce
que je travaille à la télé je vais leur
téléphoner pour leur dire comment
comment ils accueillent les touristes
ici vous le prenez comme ça voilà alors
votre portable voilà non non
je peux pas travailler demain
aussi je vais le dire à la télé on a
rien fait
un agent de force de l'ordre alors je je
je
ne le
monsieur non je ne m'excuse monsieur ça
veut rien dire
[Musique]
ça fait des inter des interférences sur
le sur le système de navigation et donc
comme il y a marée basse vous voyez vous
vous venez au commissariat alors
de suite alors parce que moi je finis ma
ronde je finis à 19h
que des enfants
[Musique]
alors hop voilà attends vous pouvez
aller le déclarer
vous avez pas le droit de faire ça vous
avez le droit vous de partir je vous ai
dit de partir
voler maintenant voilà vous allez le
déclarer noyer c'est pas frais
j'ai toutes mes cartes commerciales qui
sont avec
et il savait pas nager
ah mais c'est pas moi qui conduit
tu commences à me casser des couilles
toi allez je te dis tu touches pas tu
touches pas à la porte
avec moi après tu m'accompagnes à
reconnaître rue du Renard
j'ai dormi un petit peu ce soir
je suis malade à l'arrière
depuis trois semaines
laisse-moi vomir
[Musique]
je suis pas bourré complètement oh là là
qu'est-ce que tu fais qu'est-ce que tu
fais d'accord développer cette citation
Dieu m'a donné la foi puis je ne sais
quoi c'est la lumière qui guide mes pas
en Dieu et après on a la lumière ça
c'est obligé
mais parfois la lumière elle marche pas
mais c'est pas la lumière du jour c'est
la lumière n'importe que vous soyez que
ça voudrait un temps vous êtes encore
avec Dieu vous êtes toujours avec vous
au grenier dans votre maison partout un
même au grenier partout et dans la cave
qui es-tu toi qui me tutoies si tu me
tutoies je te tutoies
laisse tomber c'est sûr
ce n'est pas parce que tu n'as jamais vu
le lion chasser qu'il est végétarien
envie de toi comme jamais envie de
personne c'est un truc de c'est un peu
chaud ça non
ça peut l'être ça dépend comment on le
comprend on comprend si on le comprend
au point de vue physique ou au point de
vue spirituel
il y a aussi le point de vue spirituel
soit à la tête quoi exactement
besoin de toi envie de personne oh
c'était un couple ringard dans les
années
75 80 85 comment il s'appelait
les filles de mon pays là il a oui c'est
court c'est citation de Enrico Macias
elles sont jolies les filles de mon pays
il faut développer
donc faut parler de la perte de
l'Algérie du regret du pays perdu
avant oui de tout son passé de toute la
nostalgie que ça évoque
dans son délire ah ouais il se drogue
alors il a rien compris
c'est un micro et puis lui
c'est pas normal la philo on s'en fout
un peu c'est ça sert pas à grand chose
j'aime pas les tricheurs
une ordure une ordure une couille
nous on s'en va avec la dame on va faire
l'amour et puis tu te démerdes
certainement pas je suis mariée
bonjour madame bonjour la télé c'est
stère à la maison
c'est vous qui avez été tiré au sort
quelque chose
merci merci
[Applaudissements]
on est bien
faudra le couper le téléphone ce soir
qu'on soit pas emmerdé
à Madame
la seule chose c'est qu'il faut que je
retourne à 6h chercher ma fille à
l'école
laissez-moi s'il vous plaît laissez-moi
[Musique]
ça y est ça marche
je vous ai dit est-ce que je sors
pas
je vous ai dit que je sors pas pour moi
c'est quoi ce bordel
[Musique]
je te parle là tu vas à toi je vais te
défoncer la tête là dans 2 secondes tu
as compris pourquoi faire tu as compris
là je te dis dégage ta gueule là
pourquoi dégage dégage je te dis connard
espèce de connard il m'a une pulvérise
avec ta vie je suis dedans ah ouais mais
ça pue c'est pas de ma faute
[Musique]
de défonce la tête là tu vois pas faire
allez ferme ta bouche fais gaffe toi tu
me connais mal toi mais moi tu me
connais pas
je travaille
de travailler là tu es con mais j'arrête
pas de travail
je suis en train de parler tu peux faire
des trucs dans ma tête ouais je suis
désolé mais ça pue à l'intérieur c'est
pas d'autre à nettoyer avant ça y est
j'ai nettoyé à côté
[Applaudissements]
de mettre des trucs pareils là devant là
[Musique]
faut pousser sinon ça marche pas
je rigole ou quoi
on fait une connerie
vous avez l'autorisation au mois de
mettre les trucs devant là et bien sûr
j'ai autorisation
non mais ça va pas ou quoi là
ouais vous allez me faire une
attestation comme quoi j'ai eu un
accident encore les
îles aussi
l'assurance c'est ça
[Musique]
je m'en fous j'ai un casque
j'ai un casque
pour protéger quoi on se demande on
n'est pas grand chose là-dedans
vous êtes d'accord pour passer à la télé
pour la caméra cachée
[Musique]
je peux prendre la table tu m'as dit oui
ah d'accord c'est pas pour longtemps
merci
vous m'avez dit la chaise bien sûr
[Rires]
quand même
on est pour un imbécile ou quoi ou quoi
vous allez prendre la table vous allez
prendre la vous voulez pas mon pantalon
aussi c'est quelqu'un
parce que moi j'ai pas envie de
plaisanter d'accord je plaisante pas et
alors laissez la table et partez
aujourd'hui c'est une mauvaise pourquoi
une nouvelle journée
et on peut prendre quoi chez toi
[Musique]